i'm still astonished that some folks
and i felt this testifying in congress
yesterday
some folks seem to really uh struggle to
let go of the status quo
astonished that right there is our
transportation secretary pete buda judge
struggling to understand why more
americans aren't as excited as he is
about buying a 50 000 electric car
secretary pete though like his boss joe
biden is actually out of touch
this time of course though most the
media is running cover for secretary
pete they never told you that he had his
driver drop off his bike so it could
look like he rode his bike to work you
know that green energy thing uh with the
suburban of course in tow the washington
post says pete in fact is number one on
the list of people to replace joe biden
in 2024
no one in the media back in 1992 was
running cover for anyone in the bush
administration and do you remember this
bush once remarked that he was quote
amazed by the barcode scanners at
grocery stores but the new york times
version of that story insinuated that he
was confused baffled by something we all
use every day according to the times
bush acted like he'd never seen a
grocery store scanner before the ap
though finally fact-checking that new
york times story from 1992
in 2018 after bush was dead here's what
the times left out of their story bush
was shown a special scanner with
advanced features including a scale to
weigh produce uncommon back then and the
ability to read barcodes even if they
were torn up and jumbled oh well too
late he was already dead and he lost his
second term of course so when we hear
secretary pete say he is astonished
that the rest of us who are dealing with
the crisis the biden administration
created don't want to do what he the
most pretentious transportation
secretary in american history wants us
to do shouldn't we be the ones who are
astonished let's talk about this now and
welcome in host of the reuben report
dave rubin author of don't burn
this country
dave i know it seems a little easy right
now
because there's so much evidence here
but pete but a judge disqualified if he
wasn't already disqualified i know all
those pot hills he didn't fill in south
bend indiana that's his resume but uh
they gave him a chance to talk and maybe
didn't didn't work out so well
well john first let me give you and your
producers a little credit there that
little two-minute intro that you did
there was fantastic and it's something
that i try to do on my show often which
is remember back to the way things used
to be and remember the way they treat
republicans or conservatives versus the
way they treat liberals or democrats
because if we don't realize that they
will keep doing it now i think one of
the reasons that big tech is always
censoring people is a lot of people are
starting to realize this ridiculous
double standard but you're right look i
refer to him as gay pete on my show
because the only reason that buddha
judge has the job as transportation
secretary is because he happens to be
gay he was not hired because he knows
anything about transportation or has any
expertise or anything else he was mayor
of south bend indiana which is a
perfectly fine city but it's a small
city and i guess he had to fill a couple
potholes but has absolutely no expertise
then spent a few months at the beginning
of his job on paternity leave
after he and his husband had kids
while we were also having a massive
supply chain issue now he's telling us
that the purpose of high gas prices is
because he wants people to feel pain so
they will go ahead and get that electric
vehicle and the irony is uh john i have
a tesla it's a wonderful vehicle it is
awe it is truly awesome elon musk has
built something that obviously is the
future but i say that knowing that
i work very hard but i have a couple
successful businesses it costs a lot of
money most people cannot afford that and
they are trying to punish
decent hard-working people for political
ends i mean think about this trip that
you mentioned to the middle east that
baited just went on he's refusing to
unleash american energy because of
climate change or something like that
but he'll go beg the saudis for their
energy i'm pretty sure we're all on
planet earth maybe not some of the
people in this administration but the
oil whether you get it over there or you
get it over here still does the same
stuff
yeah and we know too you convert into
electric vehicles and you came out as
gay because just for the jokes right
now that's not going to be that's not
going to be the only science reference
there's anything wrong with that
we're going to get three seinfeld
references in with dave today but i
first want to talk about what you just
said the the censorship of conservatives
on social media i mean this is something
we know but we get more evidence about
how bad it is all the time the media
research center found that big tech
constantly discriminates against
conservatives
over 144 million social media users were
kept from conservatives in the first
quarter of 2022 alone so they're shadow
banning folks dave and just for you know
not to i i don't have a lot of social
media followers but i've been on truth
for like a couple months and i've
already exceeded my twitter followers on
truth
and i think a lot of people are sharing
their same experiences
there is something very interesting
going on at truth social uh that is not
happening on twitter which is that it
seems to be unmanipulated i just got on
truth social about two weeks ago because
i was banned on twitter because
apparently i called elliott paige ellen
page ellen page used to be an actress
who is an x-men apparently she's a man
now who wasn't in x-men or something
like that i'm very confused about what
happened it's confusing
i was banned for that i was also banned
last summer when i said that the
vaccines aren't working as promised and
that federal mandates were coming i was
banned for that back then eventually
they let me back on uh but yes there are
alternatives i would also welcome people
to check out locals.com they should
check out rumble because the the simple
truth is
we know we're being banned and shadow
banned and suspended and all of those
things but it is not the stuff we know
of that i'm worried about it's all of
the stuff we do not know that they are
doing how they are showing you certain
videos and not showing you other videos
whether they amplify certain political
views into your feed and hide other
views we only know a small set of things
that we think that they're doing there
is probably a much wider set and if you
think that now years after we've all
been screaming about this that suddenly
twitter or facebook or youtube or
instagram is going to fix any of this
then i got a bridge to alaska to sell
you because they're not gonna fix any of
it so it's baked in it's a feature not a
bug right uh you have to start at home
and it starts with real conversations
and real action not on social media
that's a good point now of course i know
we're all wishing president biden the
best we hope you recover some covet as
quickly as possible we've got to talk
about
his cancer that he talked about
yesterday he says he got cancer
apparently from the coal the fossil fuel
industry somehow the white house has
since had to clarify that they were just
talking about non-melanoma skin cancers
he had removed before he took office um
but no matter what type of cancer it is
it is serious as we learn from jerry
seinfeld in this
iconic moment
you call yourself lifesaver i call you
pimple poppermd
perry how are you i just want to thank
you again for saving my life
she saved your life i had skin cancer
skin cancer
skin cancer i too have had non-melanoma
skin cancers removed from me dave and i
hope again the president
recovers quickly from covid
john uh first off i just have to tell
you by far my favorite cable news host
you're doing a fine job it's really not
that hard dave all i gotta do is play
seinfeld clips for you and simpson clips
and and make you happy that's it's easy
i don't ask much i don't ask much but
you're doing a fine job um look as far
as let me just talk about the coveting
for one second of look he's the he's the
pilot of the plane right now whether
whether you want him to be or not i i
wish joe biden well we know he has a
series of other physical and mental
problems and they're going to have to
deal with that and it's becoming too
hard to hide but that's separate then i
don't wish this guy or anyone else ill
and you know of course the other just to
go to the political part i mean the
other part is that kamala harris then
becomes president if
uh he steps aside so that's one thing as
far as the bumbling on that you know
they're they're claiming that he just
made a tense problem you know that i had
cancer he said i have as opposed to i
had um but it just goes to the broader
point of that there is so little
uh validity to what he says there is so
little honesty in what he says or
understanding when he's saying it that
for about 10 minutes online when the
president said i have cancer people were
freaking out and then by 10 minutes
passed and everyone was like ah it was
just biden being biden that is a problem
regardless of whether he has coveted
cancer or excessive flatulence yes uh
it's a tense problem just like he didn't
say read the line again he said i'm
going to repeat yeah
and then they go back and change they go
back and change the transcript to
reflect what he said even though he made
the it's all it's so bad and of course
democrat privilege man that's the one
privilege there is in the united states
yeah there's a lot of that dave rubin
we'll see you online great to see you as
always good to see you john if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell